okay I'm sitting here with the - and I'm
looking forward to to do a quick
interview with him about his tournament
in Stavanger are you happy with your
performance I don't know what do you
think about my play well it started off
quite good I was watching the Blitz from
from abroad but I was really proud of
you at least at the during the first
eight runs and then you had seven half
out of eight so I was optimistic when
you started the tournament and yeah I
was you read the first round I've got a
little bit worried because he spent so
much time and it was a new time control
did you have full control no uh if I if
I'd had control them well we wouldn't
have spent so much time but I thought it
was still a good first round game
I don't usually play so well in first
round especially if I haven't played for
for a while so the level line itself was
quite good but time management and some
of the decisions in in time travel was
was they were not very good so I think
my my general feelings from the
tournament is that I started off I
started off well the the first three
rounds the rest of the tournament wasn't
great frankly um but yeah I made it in
the end um it's probably good for me to
lose a game with Aronian because sort of
gotten used to to not losing and not
making difficult decisions uh then I
very happy that I managed to to play one
good game the final game to finish it up
so we were satisfied with the final game
as early on yeah I'm not satisfied with
the way
the opening I think was a little bit too
much but but after that I felt like I
played himself but I will have to thank
the organizers for for you know actually
managing to organize this tournament so
many times I could finally win yeah I
believe it was fourth time we're very
thankful for for that and hopefully in
the future I can repay their their hard
work and even one yeah so what's your
next challenges knob oh well my next
tournaments are in Paris and Brussels
rapid and blitz in in June very much
looking forward to that when you win the
tournament but you feel that you can do
even better than you're both encouraged
by the result and also and also inspired
to to do even more
that's a probably very good result of
the tournament that is you get you get
to win it and you're also inspired to
improve yeah next one I think if you're
not adult self-critical then you will
will not improve but one should not one
should also be able to enjoy the good
result even if even if I feel that still
feel like I can I can improve yeah
that's good
the final question I'll surely follow
the Garris games in said Luis how was
your impression of his kind of comeback
and it's at least um I am thinking
played very well I felt that Nakamura
was a bit intimidated playing him he
absolutely dominated Cara ah and I'm
very very impressed with with what he
did and frankly not too impressed
with the others but whatever love to get
to have gotten a chance to to be in that
field myself and I feel like I'm on a
good day I could have done very well
there yeah okay thank you yeah thank you
and see you next time